thank you Mr Speaker and may I welcome
the Prime Minister the first British
Asian prime minister is a significant
moment in our national story and it's a
reminder that for all the challenges we
face as a country Britain is a place
where people of all Races and all
beliefs can fulfill their dreams
that's not true in every country and
many didn't and many didn't think that
they would live to see the day when it
would be true here it's part of what
makes us all so proud to be British
was his Home Secretary right to resign
last week for a breach of security
[Music]
for his kind and indeed generous uh
welcome to the dispatch box I look
forward to Primus question time with him
and I know that we will have no doubt
robust exchanges but I hope that they
can also be serious and grown up so I
look forward to it well look he he asked
about the hometown the Home Secretary
made an error of judgment but she
recognized that she raised the matter
and she accepted her mistake and that's
why that's why I was delighted to
welcome back into a United cabinet that
brings experience
and stability to the heart of government
and let me tell you Mr Speaker what the
Home Secretary will be focused on she'll
be focused on cracking down on criminals
defending our borders
well the party opposite remains soft on
crime and in favor of unlimited
immigration
Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker yesterday the Prime Minister
stood on the steps of Downing Street and
promised Integrity professionalism and
accountability but then with his first
act he appointed a Home Secretary who
was sacked by his predecessor a week ago
for deliberately pinging around
sensitive home office documents from her
personal account
um far from soft on crime I ran the
crown prosecution service for five years
[Applause]
to take on terrorists and serious
organized crime and I know firsthand how
important it is that we have a Home
Secretary whose integrity and
professionalism are Beyond question
so have officials raised concerns about
his decision to appoint her
[Music]
Mr Mr Speaker I just addressed the issue
with the Home Secretary but but he uh he
talked about fighting crime I would hope
[Applause]
speaker I would hope that he would
welcome I would hope I would hope that
as we look forward he would welcome the
news today that there are over 15 000
new police officers
[Music]
and the Home Secretary will be
supporting them to tackle burglaries
well the party opposite the party
opposite will be backing The Lunatic
protesting Fringe that are stopping
through working
but well Mr Speaker I listen carefully
that was clearly not a no
we can all see what's happened here he's
so weak he's done a grubby deal trading
National Security because he was scared
to lose another leadership election
there's a new Tory at the top but us
always with them party first country
second
yesterday yesterday
on the steps of Downing Street he also
admitted what the whole country knows
the Tories have crashed the economy and
now somebody has to pay for their mess I
say it shouldn't be working people
who've been hammered Time and Again by
this lot but those with the broadest
shoulders must Step Up does he agree
well Mr Speaker The Honorable gentleman
talked about party first and Country
second perhaps he could explain to us
well it was a few years ago he was
supporting the member for Islington
North
let's go
Mr Speaker
my record is clear when times are
difficult in this country I will always
protect the most vulnerable that is the
values of our compassionate Authority
we did it in covid and we will do that
again
Mr Speaker he says he'll protect the
most vulnerable Let's test that the
government currently allows very rich
people to live here but register abroad
for tax purposes I don't need to explain
to the Prime Minister how non-dom status
Works he already knows all about that
it cost the treasury 3.2 billion pounds
every year
why doesn't he put his mouth where's
money where his mouth is I get rid of it
well Mr Speaker I have belongs we will
have to take difficult decisions to
restore economic stability and
confidence and my honorable friend the
chancellor will set that out at an
Autumn statement in just a few weeks but
what I can say as we did during covid we
will always protect the most vulnerable
we will do this no fair way but what I
can say I am glad Mr Speaker that the
party opposite honorable gentleman has
finally realized that spending does need
to be paid for
it is a novel concept for the party
opposite this government is going to
restore economic stability and we will
do it in a fair and compassionate way
[Applause]
I know it's been away for a few weeks
but you should have listened what's been
going on the last two
I have to say I'm surprised he's still
defending non-dom status he pretends
he's on the side of working people but
in private he says something very
different over the summer he was
secretly recorded at a garden party in
Tunbridge Wells
boasting to a group of Tory members that
he personally moved money away from
deprived areas to wealthy places instead
rather than apologize or pretend that he
meant something else why doesn't he now
do the right thing and undo the changes
that he made to those funding formulas
[Applause]
I know
[Applause]
I know I I know the right I know the
right honorable gentleman rarely Leaves
North London
but if he does but if if he does he will
know that there are deprived areas in
our rural communities and
across the South and this government
will relentlessly support them because
we are a government that will deliver
for people across the United Kingdom Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker he mentioned the last
few weeks I am the first to admit that
mistakes were made and that's the reason
I am standing here but that but that is
the difference between him and me this
summer I was talking I was being honest
about the difficulties that we were
facing but when he ran for leader when
he ran for leader he promised his party
he would borrow billions and billions of
how
of how I told the truth for the good of
the country he told his party what it
wanted to hear leadership is not selling
fairy tales it is confronting challenges
and that is the leadership the British
people will get from this government
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
I think everyone should watch the video
and make their own minds up in public he
claims he wants to level up the North
but then he boasts about trying to
funnel vital investment away from
deprived areas he says one thing and
does another
well that's shouting
they're not my words they're not my
words
they're the words of the former chair of
the Tory party sat yesterday for telling
the truth about the Prime Minister even
his own side no he's not on the side of
working people that's why the only time
he ran in a competitive election he got
trounced by the former prime minister
who herself got beaten by a lettuce
so why doesn't he put it to the test let
working people have their say and call a
general election
[Applause]
well it'll take a long time to get
through this paper if we carry on like
those prime minister
Mr Speaker he talks about mandates about
votes about elections it's a bit Rich
coming from the person who tried to
overturn the biggest Democratic vote
oh our mandate is based on a Manifesto
that we were elected on to remind him an
election that we won and they lost
a mandate that says we want a stronger
NHS better schools safer streets control
of our borders and leveling up that is
the Mandate that I and this government
will deliver for the British people
[Applause]